[Music]
you done reload
everybody out
Mo you
done you're a blessing Mr Clay this
place was crab grass and weeds and you
brought it back to
life Mrs Parker and I were friends she
was like family she was the only person
who ever took care of
me I just got a message saying that
there's a problem with my computer yes
ma'am we got
this here today she shot herself this is
private property do you know what they
do here scamming the weakest in our
society buddy I'm count to three 1 2
three
there I did it for
you no you can't take it no you I'm
going to burn this place to the
ground will you stomp his ass
out they telling me one man did this the
only thing you know is he's a
beekeeper a beekeeper beekeeper well
that's not
good beekeepers is special program
outside the chain of command I protect
the hive when the system is out of
balance I correct it we have WS for
these things until they fail then you
have
me my fingers they cut them off what the
[__] bro don't
move Bow Down
this is much bigger than a little
fishing
scam going
get the money is going all over the
world to people in finance even
government you are a problem God damn
right I'm a
problem no way he's coming here straight
through the back entrance I figured I'd
give the firefighters a break somebody
need to tame this
guy
die we have to kill him before he kills
his way to the
top
honey it's flammable as [__] who
know
[Music]